madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer le premier
procès en assises du tourisme sexuel
un homme comparaît à paris pour avoir
abusé d'une petite thaïlandaise retour
au calme progressif au proche orient des
signes de normalisation apparaissent
comme la réouverture de l'aéroport de
gaza
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux sur
les arabes israéliens enfin le salon
d'automne sous vos nouvelles
technologies avec la présence pour la
première fois d'artistes numériques mais
d'abord l'histoire de ce jurassique
microbes une bactérie qui restait en
suspension pendant 250 millions d'années
plongez dans une solution organique le
microbe s'est réveillé il est intact et
bien sûr toutes les précautions étaient
prises pour qu'il n'y ait aucune
contamination claire perdrix ce petit
morceau de cristal recèle un véritable
scoop scientifique
le microbe le plus vieux du monde il ya
250 millions d'années et se porte comme
un charme
la bactérie a été retrouvé à 569 m sous
terre au nouveau mexique par des
chercheurs américains
elle est restée niché dans un cristal de
sel une sorte d'hibernation grand luxe
qui offre à tous les scientifiques de la
planète
un véritable voyage dans le temps je
dirais ça nous donne une image de
comment était une bactérie il y a deux
sens et rock non d'années on a les
équivalents de nos jours quand des noms
un petit peu différent mais qui sont en
fait les lointains descendants
on sait comment ces bactéries de nos
jours fonctionne on les a beaucoup
analysé
donc c'est un intérêt très fondamentales
prévues évolution par où on était
comment ça a changé entre-temps la
bactérie s'avère être un bacille cousin
éloigné des microbes retrouver dans les
salins de la mer morte elle ne
représente a priori aucun danger de
contamination mais a quand même été
placé sous haute surveillance à
l'université de pennsylvanie
les chercheurs étudient désormais son
génome autrement dit son empreinte
génétique qui sait ce petit microbes
pourrait en plus se révéler utile et des
bactéries du même genre qui sont connus
qu'avec tant productrice d'enzymes qu'on
utilise dans la vie de tous les jours
mais aussi productrice d'antibiotiques
donc il se peut que cette bactérie là
qui maintenant potentiellement a disparu
du globe
savait faire une substance dont la
recette était perdue depuis et qui
pourraient maintenant s'avérer utile et
donc pas tous qui pourrait nous servir
aussi bien le domaine de la delà de la
pharmacie que dans la vie de tous les
jours au delà des applications concrètes
le mathusalem des microbes nous offre
déjà une certitude la vie peut durer un
quart de milliard d'années voilà qui
laisse rêveur
la justice n'a pas de frontières en
matière de pédophilie un français
comparaît depuis ce matin en cour
d'assises pour avoir abusé d'une
fillette de 12 ans à pattaya en
thaïlande
plus largement c'est la pratique du
tourisme sexuel qui est remise en cause
la fillette qui est devenue une
adolescente de 18 ans a décidé de venir
témoigner au procès compte rendu
d'audience nathalie cause luc hedrich
cette jeune thaïlandaise avec un foulard
est venu en france pour assister au
procès de son agresseur
en 94 elle avait 12 ans lorsqu'un
français en vacances à pattaya lui a
imposé des relations sexuelles
il l'avait payé 21 francs à moins de se
mouiller comparaît aujourd'hui devant la
cour d'assises de paris pour viols sur
mineure un violent filmées à l'époque
par ses compagnons de voyage je ne sais
pas si tout le monde est conscient de la
gravité qu'il y a
pour un moment de plaisir pour un
souvenir vacances parce que le prévenu
dit que là-bas ça semble normal de
martyriser de traumatiser un enfant qui
ensuite vous l'avez entendu ce matin
abandonné l'école est maintenant à la
dérision
agnès fournier de saint maur membres
d'interpol et plusieurs policiers ont
raconté le déroulement de l'enquêté
pointent en 97
la police suisse saisie chez un
pédophile les cassettes vidéo réalisée à
pattaya cette cassette a permis
d'identifier la jeune thaïlandaise et
son agresseur une preuve accablante
diffusée aujourd'hui devant la cour
décide liga je le répète ce conte est
très particulier il faut voir les images
de batailles un ville entièrement
organisée autour de la prostitution avec
des milliers de prostituées dans des
bars à ciel ouvert et je crois qu'un
homme qui passe des vacances là-bas pour
peu qu'il ait un peu moins de repères de
la moyenne et bien va se laisser
progressivement entraîner va perdre les
repères qui peut avoir lorsqu'il se
trouve dans son pays d'origine
un méchoui premier français à
comparaître devant une cour d'assises
pour un viol commis à l'étranger risque
une peine de 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle
une loi de 1994 permet de poursuivre les
auteurs de délits sexuels
même si leurs victimes étrangères sont
rarement retrouvées par les enquêteurs
justice toujours avec un deuxième
jugement beaucoup plus clément pour les
époux bardet qui avait été accusée d'
esclavage moderne envers une jeune
togolaise en appel il écope finalement
d'une amende de 10000 francs alors qu'en
première instance il avait été condamné
à de la prison ferme
le procès des frères jourdain maintenant
et les deux assassins présumés nient
toujours leur participation au quadruple
meurtre du portel et s'accusent
mutuellement
aujourd'hui les policiers les experts
sont venus à la barre pour tenter de les
confondre le reportage aux assises du
pas-de-calais d'arnaud ardoin et de
sergio roseanne strauss chez luc frémiot
l'avocat général qui a tiré le premier
il s'adresse aux frères jourdain
messieurs j'en ai assez de vos négation
systématique
je veux des réponses maintenant d
aux propos du commissaire muller qui a
diligenté une enquête du srpj de lille
en 97
pour lui il y a eu co-action absolue des
deux hommes à bord d'une camionnette
acheter comme on achète une arme
les réponses aussi aux affirmations du
médecin légiste pour lui les violences
physiques et sexuelles sont telles
qu'elles n'ont pas pu être faite par un
seul homme pour moi je pense que jean
michel jourdain est parfaitement capable
de tabac c'est entre guillemets quatre
jeunes filles et d'avoir laissé sur leur
corps les traces qu'on a trouvé jean
louis continue donc d'accuser son frère
tandis que jean-michel justifie ses
aveux partiels en cours de garde à vue
il donne des détails sur les
déguisements que portaient les filles le
soir du drame étonnant pour quelqu'un
qui dit finalement ne pas les avoir vus
c'est un policier de boulogne qui me les
a décrits je crains vraiment qui il est
et qu'ils campent sur leurs positions
jusqu'au bout à nous démontrer qu'elles
sont adressant blabla mais je pense
qu'au fur et à mesure qu'on avance dans
le dossier
les jurés s'en rendent bien compte
l'invraisemblance elle
manifeste la vente à aucun moment les
faits un jour d'un nom paru réellement
déstabiliser même canton fin d'audience
un ancien détenu de la prison de
longuenesse affirme à la barre avoir
entendu jean louis jourdain revendiquer
l'un des meurtres
son frère ayant commis les trois autres
là encore les accusés n'ont pas bronché
ils ont nié premiers résultats de topsy
trois semaines après la mort de la
petite marine la fillette est morte
asphyxiée sans que l'on sache encore
s'il s'agit d'un accident ou d'un acte
criminel
la déclaration du procureur cet après
midi mais ces examens ne permettent pas
de confirmer si la fillette retrouvée à
demi dévêtus a été violée ou pas à quel
moment la cassette costume de jean
claude méry at-elle été réellement
enregistrée dans quelles conditions et
pour quel usage
ce sont quelques unes des questions
auxquelles les juges d'instruction
chargés du dossier tente de répondre des
juges d'autant plus intrigué que les
dates avancées par les avocats belot et
guillou ne sont pas les mêmes que celles
avancées par arnaud hamelin le
journaliste producteur dont l'agenda est
aussi au centre des recherches le point
avec alain chabot et joseph tual
il était fatigué et peu bavard le
journaliste arnaud hamla ici à sa sortie
hier du bureau du juge venait d'être mis
en examens recel de violation de secret
professionnel
ça n'a pas de sens at il fait savoir
depuis arnaud hamelin est l'auteur de la
fameuse interview costume de jean claude
méry une cassette explosif pour jacques
chirac et le rpr sa société de
production avait déjà fait l'objet d'une
perquisition en règle au lendemain de la
publication du document
voici un mois mais aujourd'hui la
justice relève des incohérences la date
d'enregistrement tout d'abord mais 96
pour hamelin décembre 95 pour l'avocat
d'un bulot les expertises démontrent que
la cassette contient un extrait de ce
match de football saint-etienne bordeaux
le 13 décembre 95 ce qui pourrait donner
raison à de l'eau et aux rames
vous pouvez avoir sur une cassette à une
image qui est micky qui reste qu'une
cassette qui a été mal effacés et puis
ensuite on enregistre six mois plus tard
donc c'est cette année léman qui donne
peut-être à penser que l'enregistrement
était fait en décembre
mais ce n'est pas une pro
absolue autre zone d'ombré deux
rendez-vous avec dominique strauss kahn
figurerait sur l'agenda d'hamelin l'un
en janvier 96 l'autre en décembre 81 18
pour qui pour quoi
détail troublant puisque dsk a reconnu
avoir détenu la cassette méry qu'en
janvier 96 monsieur strauss kahn était
avocat il n'était pas ministre
donc mon client qu'il n'a pas rencontré
aurait parfaitement pu le rencontrer
fortuitement avec des seins d'autres
amis et et et voilà pourquoi ces
questions date à mes yeux sont tout à
fait secondaire les deux hommes ont fait
savoir chacun de leur côté qu'ils ne
s'étaient jamais rencontrés quant à karl
lagerfeld dont le nom figure également
sur l'agenda d'hamelin il ne serait
qu'un contact professionnel selon le
journaliste le couturier bénéficiaire
d'un dégrèvement fiscal exceptionnel
quand dsk était encore ministre des
finances décidément la ferme et riz
suscite jour après jour davantage
d'interrogations au proche orient le
calme semble revenir peu à peu dans les
territoires des signes de normalisation
sont visibles avec la réouverture
aujourd'hui l'aéroport de gaza et du
principal terminal routier mais la
tension est toujours très forte et les
affrontements sporadiques ont éclaté
notamment à naplouse où un palestinien a
été tué par des colons juifs
rungis nussbaum le premier avion
palestiniens autorisés à décoller de
gaza à destination du caire en egypte
l'aéroport de gaza a rouvert ses portes
ce matin après quinze jours de blocage
total conformément aux accords de charm
el cheikh
quelques heures auparavant l'armée
israélienne avait commencé à démanteler
ces barrages installés autour de la
ville de naplouse en cisjordanie israël
a également levé en partie le blocus de
gaza
depuis ce matin les camions empruntent à
nouveau le passage de karni pour
approvisionner la bande de gaza mais ce
retour progressif à la normale n'a pas
empêché de nouveaux affrontements à
hébron malgré une suspension du couvre
feu
des heurts ont opposé de jeunes lanceurs
de pierres palestiniens aux soldats
israéliens qui ont répliqué par des tirs
de balles caoutchoutées
même échauffourées ars à la frontière
entre israël et la bande de gaza
mais les incidents les plus graves ont
eu lieu près de naplouse en cisjordanie
les échanges de tirs ont commencé dans
les champs entre habitant d'une colonie
juive et palestiniens avant que l'armée
israélienne intervienne un palestinien
est mort et plusieurs autres ont été
blessés ce soir le gouvernement
israélien et l'autorité palestinienne se
rejettent mutuellement la responsabilité
des affrontements
pendant ce temps au caire le sommet
arabe s'est ouverte par une minute de
silence à la mémoire des palestiniens
tués depuis le 28 septembre dernier les
pays arabes devraient lancer un
ultimatum à l'état hébreu pour qu'il
respecte ses engagements faute de quoi
l'egypte et la jordanie pourrait
reconsidérer leurs relations avec tel
aviv
parmi les populations les plus exposées
danse dans ce conflit il ya bien sûr les
arabes israéliens
ils représentent 12 % de la population
et se sentent aujourd'hui en rupture
complète avec les juifs israéliens alors
qu'ils font partie du même pays
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux à
nazareth philippe denis et stéphane
taponier nazareth a du mal à digérer ces
troubles des derniers jours ici dans la
première ville arabe d'israël
trois arabes ont été tués la semaine
dernière les heurts avec les voisins
juifs ont été violents et les habitants
chrétiens comme musulmans accusent la
police israélienne d'avoir à leur prix
partie
oui nous voulions simplement manifester
contre sharon de manière pacifique
cet étudiant mais les policiers n'ont de
protéger personne
ce sont eux qui se sont montrés cet
épisode a été une goutte d'eau mais il a
fait déborder tous les ressentiments
plus ancien des arabes israéliens de
nazareth
quand nous demandons à la police de
venir quand il y a quelques problèmes
qui se posent dans la ville et qu'on
téléphone à la police
venez voir ya des soûlards il ya des
gens qui cassent des bouteilles il y
associe ou de la personne qui bien au
fond nous avons toujours été déjà depuis
très longtemps
nous nous parlons tous les domaines
nous constatons de grande discrimination
dans le traitement des arabes israéliens
par rapport aux longs il est évident que
cette situation est potentiellement
explosive elle explosera à la première
occasion est ok à un kilomètre du bureau
du maire arabe de nazareth à la
municipalité juif de nazareth illit tu
le discours est tout à fait différent le
bénin yves h lun
tout allait bien jusqu ici nos relations
avec nos voisins étaient tout à fait
cordiale à tout point de vue personnel
ou commercial
les violences ont été comme une éruption
volcanique inattendu au bout de dix
jours c'est vrai que les gens de
nazareth elite se sont défendus méthode
pour tout mais maintenant je pense que
le calme est revenu lâche
comme la mairie de nazareth elite le
gouvernement israélien a longtemps
minimisé le problème de ces citoyens
arabes tel aviv préfère souligner qu'ils
gagnent des salaires dix fois supérieure
aux palestiniens des territoires
mais à nazareth l'amertume est grande et
pourrait à tout moment se muer à nouveau
en révolte
l'europe tente de séduire l'asie les
chefs d'état des quinze ont fait le
déplacement jusqu'en corée pour un
sommet exceptionnel europe asie des
européens qui veulent consolider leur
position économique dans un marché très
porteur
mais qui se retrouvent sur ce terrain
dans un contexte de grande concurrence
avec les états unis à séoul nos envoyés
spéciaux mémona hintermann et
jean-jacques le deuil c'est le pays du
matin calme
surtout le pays d'une formidable énergie
en l'espace d'une génération l'accord et
a construit de puissance économique sur
les décombres de la guerre
47 millions d'habitants la
quasi-totalité employés de l'industrie
et les services
après la grave crise financière de 1997
l'accord et se remet sur les rails dix
pour cent de croissance l'an dernier ici
la france veut conquérir plus de place
pour elle et pour l'europe
jacques chirac l'a dit au président kim
dae jung un démocrate
auréolé de son récent prix nobel de la
paix c'est aussi le sens de son appel
aux investisseurs coréens devant 140
chefs d'entreprise venus de toutes les
régions de france
exposer la haute technologie et le luxe
français à séoul
je souhaite que d'autres entreprises
coréennes voit tout ce que notre pays''
ces hommes ces femmes parmi les mieux
qualifiés ses infrastructures sa
situation au sein de l'europe peuvent
leur apporter dans leurs projets de
développement
les entretiens politiques ont porté sur
le rapprochement des deux corées à 1h30
de séoul
le face à face nord sud chaque jour le
même rituel
la dernière frontière de la guerre
froide au sud
trente sept mille soldats américains
s'entraînent toujours comme si rien
n'avait changé depuis les années 50 pour
expliquer que le monde a changé
les quinze chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de l'union européenne
commencent ce soir un sommet ambitieux
avec l'asie l'europe doit donc défier
les etats-unis de 20 pays qui a été
longtemps leur chasse gardée
mais les européens agissent en ordre
dispersé dans la région après l'italie
il est quelques jours la grande bretagne
annonce l'ouverture de relations
diplomatiques avec la corée du nord pour
la france et pour l'allemagne
il est encore trop tôt
dès la semaine prochaine les américains
vont contre attaque et madeleine
albright le chef de la diplomatie
américaine fera une visite historique en
corée du nord et préparer celle de bill
clinton
l'europe toujours cette fois au chevet
de sa monnaie tout les gouverneurs de la
banque centrale européenne était réunie
aujourd'hui à paris il s'agissait pour
eux d'exprimer leur solidarité à wismes
duisans baer le patron de la banque
centrale européenne hier en quelques
mots il a fait chuter l'euro à son plus
bas niveau historique et on a même parlé
de démission
marc bruckert nathalie berthier aux
côtés du président de la banque centrale
européenne winden berg jean claude
trichet gouverneur de la banque de
france christian noyer vice président de
la bce tous unis contre la tempête
à l'origine de cette tempête une gaffe
de wim duisenberg alors que l'euro
baisse régulièrement dans une interview
au times il a exclu toute intervention
de la banque centrale européenne pendant
la crise du proche orient
résultat une rapide descente aux enfers
pour l'euro qui ne s'en est toujours pas
remis
aujourd'hui la presse internationale a
réclamé des explications
en vingt huit dizaine berg et rester
bouche cousue
je ne répondrai plus à aucune question à
propos de cette interview récente
je confirme notre politique qui est
d'ailleurs connue et j'ai l'intervention
est un outil elle que les banques
centrales utilisent si et quand c'est
approprié problème
l'interview de dreezen berg a suscité
une volée de critiques des gouvernements
italiens allemands et même en france où
l'assemblée s'inquiète de la politique
monétaire européenne et demande à ce
titre a auditionné monsieur trichet de
26 octobre prochain met wimbee szenberg
fait front il affirme que sa politique
est la bonne sofia le conseil des
gouverneurs estime que les 22 premiers
mois de l'union monétaire européenne
on s'était un vrai succès c'est
déterminant pour continuer à relever les
défis de la politique monétaire
en attendant les rumeurs d'une possible
démission de huit dizaine berg
continuent d'aller bon train malgré le
soutien affirmé dégoût
en heure des 15 pays de l'euro ce matin
à paris le président de la banque
centrale européenne désormais fragilisée
a vécu d'une des journées les plus
difficiles de sa carrière
des larmes en politique l'image est
plutôt rare la scène s'est passée ce
matin lors de la passation de pouvoir
entre martine aubry qui laissait sa
place au ministère de l'emploi et de la
solidarité à elisabeth guigou martine
aubry vous allez voir qu'il n'a pu
retenir ses larmes alors qu'elisabeth
guigou elle même était très ému je
voyais les deux femmes middle class
action
quarante huit heures après l'accident de
train qui a fait quatre morts en
grande-bretagne la société railtrack a
confirmé que la portion de raï concerné
est en mauvais état et que ce manque
d'entretien étaient à l'origine de
l'accident
le directeur général a présenté sa
démission elle a été refusée par le
conseil d'administration
c'est dans ce contexte que des cheminots
français organisé cet après midi une
manifestation à paris ils étaient 35
milles il refuse que ce secteur soit peu
à peu libéralisé en invoquant justement
le problème de la sécurité mais aussi la
desserte des petites lignes de province
amylie des lois laurent sourds
et motivait ils étaient 35 mille selon
les manifestants disent est tenu selon
la préfecture
ce que veulent les cheminots s'est évité
que le transport ferroviaire ne soit
libéralisé comme le parlement européen a
décidé
les français ne sont pas les seuls à
refuser l'ouverture à la concurrence du
transport ferroviaire
cet après midi une centaine de cheminots
belges ou les filets avec eux et
d'ouverture des nouveaux entrants qui
n'ont pas fait leurs preuves et on met
pour une tradition de service public
en belgique comme pour les pentes selon
me cheminots la coopération européenne
ne doit pas mettre en danger ce service
public
si demain des opérateurs privés entre
dans les secteurs ferroviaires les
syndicats craignent que la sncf ne
souhaite obligés de casser le statut des
cheminots ya besoin de développer le
transport ferroviaire du groupe est
stable et on peut le faire sur une base
de coopération à partir des entreprises
nationales qui existe et en préservant
les statuts des personnels qui existe
les cheminots refuse aussi que la sncf
se sépare d'un certain nombre
d'activités pour être plus compétitif
c'est déjà le cas pour la restauration
dans les trains mais les syndicats
veulent aujourd'hui endiguer ce
processus aujourd'hui qu'ils ont choisi
de pousser au bout la déréglementation
et prennent des risques des risques
ferroviaire important séparait la pra
structure de l'entreprise de transport
s'est séparé le rail de la roue et c'est
risqué
le déraillement c'est malheureusement ce
qui se passe en angleterre aujourd'hui
ce matin jean claude gayssot les a
rassurés sur l'avenir du service public
ferroviaire le 22 novembre à bruxelles
il devrait défendre ce service public
contre le paquet ferroviaire du
parlement européen il y présidera en
effet le conseil des ministres des
transports
mais la présidence française prend fin
en décembre
prudence si vous devez prendre l'avion
ce week-end une grève de quatre jours va
toucher à france à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats de personnel navigant
technique pour les 35 heures
une centaine de vols intérieurs au moyen
courriers devraient être perturbés un
numéro est à votre disposition pour vous
renseigner le 0 820 820 820 et un
internet à deux chalutiers pris dans la
tempête c'est dernière au large de la
bretagne et de la vendée le premier a
fait naufrage au large des sables
d'olonne
un marin est porté disparu les deux
autres ont été récupérés sains et saufs
l'autre dans le finistère près du port
de plouescat deux marins sont passés par
dessus bord emporté par une déferlante
alors qu'il remontait leurs casiers le
salon d'automne et depuis le début du
siècle l'un des grands rendez-vous de la
peinture le public qui a notamment
découvert le pubis nous encore le
fauvisme et cette année les
organisateurs s'attachent à faire
découvrir les nouvelles technologies ce
qu'on appelle les artistes numériques
qui réalisent leurs oeuvres à partir
d'un écran d'ordinateur
portrait de l'un d'entre eux avec
marie-claire tiers et jean christophe
duclos artistes ou ingénieur claude
massot créé sur son ordinateur des
oeuvres virtuel comme cette sculpture
synectics en matière qui flottent dans
l'espace sans pesanteur ni gravité un
art en liberté ou ses portraits qu'il
peut aussi imprimer sur du papier ou sur
de la toile
dans cet atelier laboratoire son
chevalet ni pinceau sans odeur ni
poussière
l'artiste comme un apprenti sorcier fait
apparaître et disparaître ses créations
à volonté comme les ordinateurs sont
plutôt destinées à des applications
industrielles enfin au grand public de
classiques de traitement de texte du
gothique
il n'y a rien de prévu bien sûr par les
constructeurs pour ce qui touche tout ce
qui touche à sa sortie stick
donc c'est à nous en quelque sorte d'un
on veut aller de l'avant à mettre au
point les supports les matériaux et
peut-être un jour les en gros si pour
pouvoir satisfaire on peut à ce besoin
de représentation de matérialisation de
l'oeuvre pour sortir ses oeuvres de son
ordinateur l'artiste a donc mis au point
une toile fine traités chimiquement pour
passer dans l'imprimante et paradoxes il
peut aussi peindre sur cette toile pour
stabiliser les couleurs claude masson
aime aussi rencontrer d'autres artistes
numériques pour partager leurs
différentes recherches scannérisation 3d
robotique un langage très codé et tous
le droit qu'elle monte un petit peu avec
cette femme à tête écran l'art est
aujourd'hui en pleine évolution
le clivage entre peinture sculpture
vidéo et cinéma disparaît car tout
devient numérique
revenons sur le titre principal de ce
journal avec le premier procès en france
pour tourisme sexuel
un homme est jugé pour avoir abusé d'une
fillette de 12 ans à pattaya en
thaïlande
il a été confondu grâce à une cassette
vidéo tournée à l'époque la victime qui
est aujourd'hui une jeune femme de 18
ans a décidé de témoigner procès le
pédophile risque jusqu'à 20 ans de
prison dans un instant le résumé tout en
images de l'actualité de votre région
puis la météo complète de fabienne
amiach à 20h50 passage à l'acte un très
beau film et ils soir 3 c'est à 22h30
excellente soirée à demain bonsoir